where are you coming from guy
i thought we were done with you
i thought we were done
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by jeremy renner he's
a two-time oscar-nominated actor whose
acclaimed credits include the hurt
locker arrival the town american hustle
and i could go on and on he has a pair
of high profile projects on the way as
well hawkeye season one which premieres
on disney plus november 24th and the
mayor of kingstown a 10 episode american
crime thriller coming to paramount plus
on november 14th jeremy renner had been
a very busy guy thanks for taking the
time for hot ones and welcome to the
show yeah thank you very much how are
you around spicy food like what's going
through your head right now as we
prepare to dig in uh i feel like we're
gonna compete or
fight okay that's what this feels like
it's set up already do something wrong
i'm gonna start swinging all right well
i'm ready i'm ready i'm ready jeremy um
yeah i like spicy food right but i like
to taste my food when it's spicy it's
supposed to just accent the food i know
as we get a little bit further along it
might be the opposite of that but i'm
always down i'm up for the challenge
dom sliding in some napkins for us just
in time a diaper
[Laughter]
so this first one will be the garlic
classic fresno yes edition
all right
[Music]
delicious
so one of your big upcoming tv projects
is the mayor kingstown a crime thriller
that's set in the rust belt what makes
the show's creator taylor sheridan who
directed you in wind river what makes
him such a master of the modern small
town american crime drama
oh he's got a very specific clear voice
um he's uh pretty fearless in how he
writes he writes very specifically and
what i love about taylor sheridan's
writing is that is equally as like
intimate and beautiful and tender as it
is
violent and ferocious and
shocking in a lot of ways but it doesn't
do it for shock value it's just all it's
all about the truths of things but
he goes to the extremes of of
human behavior and
in his storytelling
with uh with those sort of extremes
okay
[Music]
i'm just it's bliss this place is nice
that is bliss
so in addition to acting i know that
you've acquired and renovated dozens of
homes over the years and then a 2014
interview with larry king compared
building a house to the closest thing to
producing a movie do you have a favorite
wood when nick offerman was on the show
he called white oak the most heroic of
woods
i mean i used iron wood on my the last
house that i built and um because it's
an exterior wood and it is goes after
its name it's um
it is like iron it's hard to even put a
nail or a screw through it it's so dense
um but it's great because it's very
lasting do you have any foundational
home decor advice that you think could
be relevant to anyone from a college kid
in their dorm room to someone vying for
the cover of architectural digest
just because it's you like it doesn't
mean it's good for the room or the whole
scene right
you know maybe the 49ers post or it's
not going to be the most appropriate
thing for the living room whatever the
fair foster poster right think about you
know the whole scope of like the room
what does the room need
uh center point uh when you walk into a
room it's a fireplace wherever it is
it's going to be the main focal point
and then work out from there i always
start with like a neutral color palette
you can always add color an art and
pillow or a throw those kind of things
and then you mix um elements with wood
and water and fire there's a fountain
use iron use fabric just mix that all
the woods all that all that kind of
stuff i think that's uh you have a good
starting point from there
the hofs
all right
[Music]
this is my breakfast
thanks off
for now
so as a movie star and gearhead can you
share a hollywood trade secret when it
comes to the art of the chase scene i
once saw you post a picture maybe from a
marvel set where it looked like the
whole thing was being diagrammed out
with like matchbox cars
oh yeah that's what the you know some of
the stunt drivers and some coordinators
will use to
to show other drivers and actors just to
show kind of the whole scope of things
but they'll use like literally these
match cards they did it we did on the
hawkeye show there's a big sequence in
there with vehicles and i kind of have
to show what's going on and and how it's
all going to run down so no one's
surprised is that typical
anytime in my experience i haven't been
in a ton of car stuff but
when there was and they were intense it
was all done with like
hot wheels
now pretty funny
[Music]
all right
no i don't even taste any heat on that
one well
kicked in later in about three minutes
you can't speak
enjoy that part of the show
i am trust me you know trust me
so if i only have an afternoon in
modesto is it better to tour the mchenry
mansion or catch a modesto nuts game at
john thurman field
hmm
wow i
you know your age i would have said just
take the next exit you know
go on
somewhere else
did you ever spend any time on like the
modesto cruise route from montgomery
boulevard to j street yeah that was that
was a very very big thing in the
community when you could actually cruise
at the time now you can't but
back then it was very very famous thing
with you know and george lucas and all
that
happening it became a very popular thing
there was the only thing that i did as a
kid we had a car on the weekend just
drive up and down mchenry and you know
see all the cars and do the thing and um
that was actually you know a fun thing
to do but then it got too ruckus and
you know people were crazy and have
disturbed the neighbors so that shut it
all down so do you remember your first
ever play or local production i was
actually able to track down on youtube i
think it's from 1990 you're playing the
scarecrow modesto community college
production of wizard of oz correct yeah
yeah that was uh the first uh
job i ever had in theater or as an actor
i'm playing the scarecrow in the wizard
of oz and that was a really great
experience man i mean it also ran um
with no act break either they decided to
make like one long just run so the kids
can really enjoy it and went to all the
schools and invited them and did the
performances for them at the schools and
i still have a lot of the um
all the kids sort of uh
responses and stuff that they that they
sent to us uh it was really really
really great it's the first sort of step
into like you know having a putting
smiles on kids faces that was a
beautiful thing
[Music]
this is uh with hot head
yeah hot heads revolutionary all right
[Music]
mm-hmm
yeah
a little bit more of a kick but nothing
you can't handle nothing too bad but
yeah a little bit more kick on that one
[ __ ] sadist
all right jeremy we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
gram we're doing deep dive on our guests
instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context so we'll show you the
picture over here on the monitor you
just tell us the bigger story
this picture is nuts what do you
remember about the mechanics of shooting
a mile and a half up the burj khalifa
with tom cruise for ghost protocol yeah
this is um when you're looking at in
this position you look down
and look everything looks like little
legos even skyscrapers
look like little legos if i fell out i
can make good two or three phone calls
before i hit the ground saying hey man
you know
i'm out i'm going down yeah it was far
it was it was so high up
gosh who is kicking
bastard
um
everyone else is like harnessed in
behind me i had one guy just holding me
with a rope on as a regular old belt and
i'm like and i'm looking back and he's
like on his cell phone i'm like if he
doesn't have me i'm going to keep
sliding out of the window
and i told him tom i was going to grab
on to anything so just be prepared
because i was
pretty terrified and until this guy i'm
like he's yelling i'm like make sure you
have me before i commit to going out
because this is before i really went all
the way out because if my body was
already it goes like this right
here i can still hold myself
but it was our conversation was pretty
funny there the safety net was a little
question it was a little questionable
yeah
how would you describe what it was like
to hit nine g's in an f-16
challenging painful
like 13 elephants sitting on you it's uh
you have to work very very hard not to
pass out
and these guys can do it so easily i
have such admiration respect for these
pilots but boy
is it it is a lot of effort
it is a lot of effort
speaking of trying not to pass out are
you ready to move on here to the back
half
yeah yeah yeah
we're already getting into it this thing
doesn't even have a nice looking label
yeah that's how you probably just gonna
imagine
this is the senor lechuga here in the
sixth spot
and the name uh-huh
[Music]
yeah it's not so bad
you know this one has a nice sort of
like cinnamony kind of entry point yeah
but then i feel like it kind of has that
time release slow burn situation yeah
i'm getting a little moist
is that normal
totally normal totally normal this crew
they've seen some things over here
but careful around your eyes that'll be
the yeah yeah yeah i'm not touching no
no trust me you see me doing this i know
a bet a hot sauce vet right there yeah
you don't wanna you wanna put it in your
eye
so in speaking broadly about the roles
that attract you i've heard you make an
interesting point about how you like to
play suppressed characters because
there's more internal nuance to figure
out yeah when things are all spelled out
for you pretty on the page like it's all
kind of out there it's it's there's
there's less room to
explore um when things are kind of
you're forced into your hand into the
creative process of understanding a
character and behavior
um
like well
you know you can still talk a lot and do
all these things but you know but when
you don't know the intention behind it
there's the coiled spring it's like
characters like you know gem in the town
or we're like well is this a good guy or
a bad guy or he's like or is he gonna
kill me or give me a hug i'm not quite
sure it's like there's that underlying
sort of coiled spring
something that's gonna come out and it's
a very actionable thing
all right this is the buddhala fire
we're just kicking it up a notch right
just
this is all matched out right yeah this
is the one
all right i'm ready the buddha fire all
right
[Music]
still tastes like chicken that's a good
time
a little peppery this one yup
nice
and speaking of uh the coil you know it
has kind of that
oh yeah
i love it
so whenever we have an actor as prolific
as you we like to fact check some of the
folklore surrounding the project totally
listen to what you're saying
is it true that you came
is it true that you became a quick study
at card tricks and learned to spit fire
when playing a street magician for your
role in the
[Music]
i like immigrant spit fire now that's
for sure
that one i had to learn this dance
routine i had to learn all these magic
tricks and slide ahead with hiding the
cards and all that stuff
and that was a fun departure of um
things that i'd done in the past
especially during those four movies
prior they're all like action stuff and
just beating people up or getting beat
up
this is actually it's a really cool
skill set and it's pretty much all i did
for three days and then i just got
pretty decent at it it was fun yeah is
there any truth to the online rumor that
you actually spent time with convicted
bank robbers to prepare for your role in
the town
yeah yeah yeah well ben only didn't say
that initially he was like just hang out
these guys just go hang out with them
and they'll take care of you and that's
where i learned the accent the thing
then they were telling me it's got to
have a 20-year bit i'm like what's a
20-year bid uh 20 years in prison i'm
like oh wow where are you in for like
well
yeah artwork car robbery and that sort
of thing no [ __ ] like yeah
and this guy is staring he's like i'm
like oh my goodness this is intense but
they you know they loved me they loved
that you know ben was part of the
process and it wasn't really ultimately
afraid but like these are guys that you
know you kind of should be afraid of but
you know they're our allies not enemies
so thank god
that's important yeah and then finally
is it true that your first ever paid
acting gig was at a local police academy
where you played the role of a criminal
perpetrator for like 50 bucks a pop yeah
yeah there was a um they really just put
me in a closet and said all you gotta do
is the police officer's gonna come knock
on the door and just don't do anything
that they say
that's like
unruly some disturbance or whatever so
i'm like okay and then they close the
door and then officer comes in again
action whatever it wasn't i'm just like
pacing back and forth hoping to publish
screaming oh [ __ ] you okay i'm going
crazy you're like
sorry excuse me sir my [ __ ] yourself
opens the door i kick him right in the
nuts
i think it went a little over the top
but you know look where it took you yeah
but i think i got paid 50 bucks and they
brought me back they did bring me back
oh recurring roll yeah yeah they brought
me back
yeah
yeah
all right jeremy are you ready to move
on here how are you doing one eye but
that's fine let's go i got one more okay
there we go
that's great i'm i'm into it
very good i got a decent sized one here
didn't i there you go okay i went for it
something serious right there i'm not
gonna lick my fingers on it but
what's this one called the bomb beyond
insanity
yoga that's [ __ ] hot story checks out
yup
[Music]
isn't it with with heat
and certain oh yeah god damn certain
parts of your tongue
it gets hotter right yeah you keep it
like on the tip maybe it won't be so hot
but it's i'm the dick that just was
savoring it right yeah i did i did see
the way that yeah you kind of it was
like a
snifter of wine yeah the way that you
kind of took that whole thing yeah this
is hot but yeah it's good i don't taste
the chicken on this one no
that's that is out the window
[Music]
yeah what's your lasting memory of
off-road racing at the baja 500 you know
my interest is
my interest was peaked when you said
that you needed a kidney belt in order
to keep your inside from getting slapped
around i have no idea what you're
talking about right now
what about a kidney belt the baja 500.
yes of off-road racing at the baja 500.
dude i got a co-drive and that
let me just
find some peace for a minute which is
fine find it
okay i'm back on earth
yeah i'm with you we're connected okay
good
yeah co-driving
interesting race where it takes two
people to drive a car
because one person's job is just to
steer and tell them the level of the
turn that's coming up and you have to
yeah you got to strap in because you're
bouncing all around
and my mouth is on fuego
yeah ready though i know that for many
years the norton commando is a prized
possession in your garage as a
motorcycle enthusiast how would you
explain the holy grail status of that
bike to someone like me
well it takes like the cool factor of
the original
where are you coming from guy
that we're done with you
i thought we were done
you're done
all right
what's great about the modern day one
has all modern day technology it keeps
the cool old factor of the old bikes
but looks like it's a little bit on
steroids give it you know like a spin
the gym so it's got a little beefiness
to it has modern technology but still
has a real cool old cafe razor styling
so that's why i love it well i'm sold
jeremy are you ready to move on here to
the next wing how you feeling you look
great
yeah okay ready
am i ready
yeah this is next it's not gonna help no
no
we're past that whatever call fire is
cranked
that was awful
but yeah i can taste the flavoring and
the spices and that and
the other one for whatever reason just
went right to i don't like you you know
what i mean
is there a dive or karaoke bar that you
missed most from your ignoble days your
early ignoble days in west hollywood
yeah there's a bunch i mean geez that
was so much part of my social life just
being broke and like i'd go out and sing
karaoke with and that's where i met most
of my friends and heck amy adams i met
there and chris pratt i met all those
peeps and
karaoke bars there was like barney's
beanery was a big one we all went
through but all over we went everywhere
j sloane's j sloane's another big one
wow we went there a lot we just half
time we're barely drinking we just go
out and
sing and because i couldn't afford to
drink or eat anyway but you know because
we'd frequent the place so much
and because we could sing we'd bring
people in and then they would buy us
drinks and food and so it's a great way
to not starve as an actor
all right
jeremy renner
what are you doing with that one
why are you shaking it we have to add to
it
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
you don't have to if you don't want to
well i mean god
why not
doesn't mean you have to eat the last
dab do you oh god oh you know there is i
guess a loophole there yeah
i'll do it
i've gone this far right
and crushed it by the way
whoa that's not a dab
it's still not a dab that is
a smatter this that's a slather it's a
pure slather
all right
i'll figure it out respect oh god cheers
jeremy
what a ride bad decision
[Music]
i make some more kick them
you know it's all over my lips
but the good news jeremy renner is that
we are now at the latest in a long line
of one degree separation from jeremy
guest that we've had on the show from
your three-time co-star elizabeth olsen
to your friend anthony mackie to
scarlett johansson who may or may not
have actually stolen beer from your
green room to quell the aftermath of
eating the bomb beyond insanity
but i want to narrow this scope
on hot one's fan favorite paul rudd yes
now that you're doing press tours on a
solo mission what do you miss most about
tag-teaming junkets with your co-star
and 50 year old virgin oh there's yeah
there's no there's no one more fun to do
just life with right i have like so much
man love for that guy
he just brings out the best in people i
guess he's got just such a wonderful way
and then we just had like the strangest
most beautiful bond
yeah that was probably the most fun
press tour that we had on a movie that
we could say nothing about
right right that's why we just came up
the idea let's just talk about this
why are we wearing each other's faces on
each other we had something to actually
talk about that's what i talked about in
kimmel and all the shows where you can
promote this movie that doesn't exist
we just had a good time doing it it's
awesome it was awesome well jeremy
renner conquering the wings of death
today look at us look at us who would
have thought not me and now there is
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you my friend this camera
this camera this camera let the people
know what you have going on in your life
fire
i have fire on my face
in my eye holes
fire
is going on in my life
like right now
hang on
uh check out uh mayor of kingstown
november 14th check out hawkeye november
24th
let's see it dr
that's the hot ones experience
yeah this is awesome
it'd be fun
my goodness
you